mon sens maurice signolet mercier de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
on l'a compris et lui de droit et l air
udi qui dénoncent un texte manquant
d'ambition le ps qui a déposé une motion
pour un retrait d'emblée trop d'un côté
pas assez de l'autre quelle juste milieu
oui je comprends je ne suis pas
parlementaire donc je me garderai bien
de rentrer dans ces polémiques deux
parties je sais que par exemple l'une
des premières volontés des groupes de
droite ou le sénat c'est de de changer
la terminologie de faire de la
sémantique et de dire de lutter contre
l'islam contre l'islamisme contre le
séparatisme
ils tiennent absolument à ce mot contre
moi simplement ce que ce que je veux
simplement retenir en français moyen est
comme un ancien policier qu'a vécu
pendant 40 ans 40 ans de police quelques
passes et je veux saluer les initiatives
du gouvernement de proposer une une
telle loi mais d'un autre côté ça
démontre à quel point la situation en
france est absolument dramatique
quand vous pensez quand on est obligé le
parlement français est aujourd'hui
obligée de débattre de la polygamie est
obligé de débattre des des certificat de
virginité de débattre des mariages
forcés
on se rend compte à quel point la
situation française est devenue
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement grave
je repensais en écoutant les
commentaires
un livre de ivan rioufol je crois qu'il
remonte à 2016 faute ans et qui avait
comme titre la guerre civile
annoncez vous voyez à quel point la
situation est vraiment extraordinaire
montant dû la droite veut réécrire le
texte vous parliez de ce mot contre
la gauche elle qui a divisé ce matin sur
public sénat le patron des sénateurs ps
patrick avec canet reparler d'un texte
déséquilibré qui l'utilisent déjà pas
les lois qui existent constat partagé
pour vous un homme de terrain
alors il est effectivement il ya des tas
de lois qui existent déjà le code pénal
réprime et des tas de textes qui sont
qui sont évoqués dans ce projet de loi
mais je vous dis là le texte même montre
bien à quel point on a une énorme
difficulté on aujourd'hui on a un énorme
problème d'intégration d'assimilation
on voit bien qu'on est obligés
aujourd'hui de parler de thèmes qu'on
n'aurait jamais abordé il ya même une
vingtaine d'années c'est surtout ça qui
est absolument absolument renversant
quelque part c'est un ca devrait
d'ailleurs je crois que les français ne
s'y trompent pas on voit bien à quel
point la situation est devenue
aujourd'hui proches presque du tsunami
un civilisationnel m'extraire à six mois
mais 40 ans de police m'ont m'ont permis
de voir cette dégradation de la société
vous savez la police est un peu un
curseur d'appréciation de la société
aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas de dire
enfin ça fait même des années qu'on
n'arrêtait pas de dire ça va mal dans
nos banlieues on ne respecte plus
l'autorité on ne respecte plus la loi
républicaine
le mou république n'a plus aucun sens
pour certains même le mou france n'a
plus de sens pour certains donc je crois
que les les les élus les sénateurs ont
fait les parlementaires dans leur
ensemble ont tout intérêt à voir en
arrière pensée cette situation un peu
particulière que vit la france
actuellement
bassam chebi nous nous a parlé du
contexte compliqué en ce moment
concrètement dans les faits sur le
terrain ce projet doit petit par exemple
empêcher un financement de la mosquée à
strasbourg par une association qui a
refusé de signer la charte des principes
de l'islam de france
ben s'il si le gouvernement retrouve l
autorité qui devrait être dans tous
présents dans tout gouvernement
normalement oui on devrait pouvoir y
arriver mais il est vrai que on va se
retrouver ne serait ce que pour
de l'école à domicile ne serait ce que
pour les mariages forcés ou est ce qu il
va falloir faire preuve au niveau
procédurales d'une acuité très
particulier à cette toutes ces
dispositions législatives vont être
enfin compte extraordinairement
difficile à mettre en application
on a parlé un de cette mosquée à
strasbourg est également les réunions
non mixtes à l'unef les propos
polémiques d'audrey pulvar ce cas cités
tout à l'heure ben hassen chébili depuis
le palais du luxembourg pour pour son
duplex en quoi ce texte peut-il freiner
la fragmentation sociétal sachant que
l'intitulé même du projet de loi ne ne
parle pas de lutte contre l'islamisme
on le rappelle aussi à toutes les
fédérations du conseil français du culte
musulman n'ont pas signé la charte des
principes de l'islam de france
voyez le fait même que qu'elle certaines
zones reculées les organisations il
s'amuse ullmann n'est pas signé ce texte
se montre bien la difficulté que l'on va
rencontrer aujourd'hui en fin de compte
moi je vous dis je c'est l'initiative du
gouvernement d'avoir fait d'avoir
proposé cette fois parce qu'il se rend
compte qu'il ya un véritable problème
mais le problème est d'une gravité
extrême et je crois qu'il faudra dans le
futur des décisions beaucoup plus
autoritaire beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus à j'allais presque dire
plus que culturel presque
civilisationnel parce que la situation
est extrêmement dramatique
on s'achemine quelque part moi j'ai j'ai
terminé ma carrière dans le 93 en
seine-saint-denis on voyait bien se
développer des isolats des isolats
culturelle alors je sais bien que
d'isola les souvent caractérisée par une
longue un peu particulière par justement
une langue qui n'est pas pratiqué par
tout le monde mais là on a des isolats
qui vont se multiplier et c'est ça la
véritable difficulté les joies comme on
veut renforcer l'intégrité de la
république on n'arrête pas de parler de
république mais j'ai l'impression que
bientôt il va falloir parler tout
simplement de la france il ya des
endroits où bien au delà de la
république c'est la france elle même qui
disparaît c'est la france elle même qui
se dé dit merci maurice signolet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes comme ici
divisionnaire honoraire